[Musique]
Monsieur Jean Lassalle bonjour bonjour
nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
Youtube qui s'appelle seriew vous êtes
candidat à la présidentielle de 2017
pour la la France euh pourquoi vous vous
engagez et qu'est-ce qui me garantit que
vous allez respecter vos promesses
pourquoi je m'engage parce que je ne
pouvais pas faire autrement euh j'étais
au modame je m'en suis je m'en suis
retiré en essayant de faire le moins de
dégâts possible parce qu'il y avait pas
de raison d'en faire j'en suis parti
comme je serais parti du PS ou des
républicains si j'avis été les partis
politiques tels qu'ils sont ne
constituent plus une réponse à l'attente
de notre pays aujourd'hui pas plus
d'ailleurs en France qu'ailleurs disons
qu'ailleurs c'est encore un peu mieux
peut-être en Allemagne et en
Grande-Bretagne mais enfin en tout cas
en France ce n'est plus le cas je
voulais je veux rassembler l'ensemble
des Français parce que c'est ceux à quoi
ils aspirent quelle est la garantie de
tenir mes promesses c'est assez simple
je vais adopter le style de Pierre mandz
France c'est-à-dire avec des
interventions fréquentes
à la télévision pour dire l'état
d'avancement et je profite de la
campagne pour essayer de toucher mes
compatriotes au cœur pour leur dire
qu'il faut mes lire mais qu'ensuite
j'auraai besoin d'eux lorsque j'aurai
des décisions difficiles à prendre et
notamment qu'il puissent descendre dans
la rue paisiblement pour me soutenir et
si je ne peux pas je leur dirai j'ai
fait un pas je ne peux pas aller plus
loin et je me retire et ça fera le plus
grand bien au peuple d'être de nouveau
reconsulté mais avant de partir j'aurais
quand même beaucoup essayé pourquoi
pourquoi vous faites référence à
l'Allemagne et à l'Angleterre je fais
référence à l'Allemagne et à
l'Angleterre parce que l'Allemagne
apparaît aujourd'hui comme le pays qui
disons s'en sort le moins mal sur la
zone euro et qui vous permet de dire ça
comme ça c'est parce que c'est dans la
tête des gà moi je il faut des chiffres
ah ah oui mais des chiffres moi je vous
dis disons que euh c'est quand même le
pays qui est le moins endetté à priori
celui qui a l'économie euh qui va le
mieux ils produisent des il il
produisent un peu de tout et notamment
tous ces ce petits produits du quotidien
que nous avons laissé partir nous euh à
l'extérieur ils ont beaucoup d'artisanat
de petits commerces précarité immense au
niveau du travail une précarité ah oui
ça c'est vrai c'est vrai mais bon je je
ne pensais pas si vous voulez je voulais
simplement donner moi l'Allemagne
pourquoi parce que dans l'esprit de tout
un chacun l'Allemagne est le moins
malade alors par contre si on en parle
après j'ai aussi effectivement des
éléments de doute sur la bonne santé de
l'Allemagne et je parlais de la
Grande-Bretagne parce que elle a fait
l'événement ces derniers mois avec le
brexit voilà vous êtes pour le le le
frxit c'est la sortie de la France non
je crois que c'est pas utile de
d'imposer à la France une fracture
supplémentaire
euh pour l'instant je suis en train
d'observer la la situation comme tous
les autres candidats hein tant de réunir
mes signature moi j'ai pas à me faire
euh je n'ai pas passé par le le vote des
militants mais euh par contre j'ai à
consulté beaucoup j'ai la chance d'avoir
une équipe euh qui SAG de jour en jour
par des experts nouveaux avec lesquels
je je travaille beaucoup euh mais je
n'ai pas encore euh réponse réponse à
tout donc
euh faire un frxit pourquoi faire euh
par contre je dois retrouver des marges
de manœuvre au niveau politique au sein
de l'Europe aucun parti aucun pays
aujourd'hui ne peut avancer dans la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes et
par exemple je vais proposer à ceux qui
le voudront de travailler comme on
travaille d'ailleurs dans la réalité
plus au niveau des États des chefs
d'État et de gouvernement pour prendre
des décisions stratégiques et
momentanément lever un petit peu le pied
sur la le grand fonctionnement de la
commission c'est c'est pas des
propositions un peu incantatoires de de
ça va être quoi vot dans la diplomatie
c'est toujours un rapport de force quel
quel va quels vont être vos levier pour
vous faire écouter mais levier pour me
faire
écouter je crois que c'est les levier
éternel de la politique en fait ce qu'on
retrouve toujours ce qui marche pas
c'estàd c'est les leviers éternels de la
politique ce qui ne marche pas ce qui
n'a jamais fonctionné donc je voulais
dire ce qui all fait marcher justement
c'est-à-dire chaque fois qu'on a fait de
la politique ce qui ne marche pas c'est
quand on fait semblant de faire de la
politique et qu'on en fait pas c'est ce
qui est le cas pour nous depuis 25 ans
25 bonnes années moi je vais proposer
très clairement de reprendre des marches
de manœuvre tout en restant dans un
contexte très proche et amical
euh mais euh je vais dire voilà je
besoin de prendre des marches de
manœuvre alors soit vous l'acceptez soit
je le fais quand même voilà c'est on a
appelé ça à un moment donné la politique
de la chaise vide et malgré tout ça a eu
quand même ses effets je ne vois pas
comment on peut sortir autrement du euh
enfin traités il y a des traités on peut
pas faire la politique de la chaise vide
il faut il faut quand même il faut que
l'Europe soit d'accord à l'unanimité
pour pour faire des choses donc
qu'est-ce que vous allez faire si si si
ça ne fonctionne pas vous allez faire un
frxit non vous vous m'avez dit que vous
allez pas faire de vous alliez pas faire
de
frxit alors pour être tout à fait
complet si vraiment je constater que il
y a une situation de blocage intégrale
dont on ne peut pas sortir en aucune
manière
euh il n'est pas interdit que je le
propose mais pas au niveau actuel euh
pourquoi parce que d'abord l'opinion
française n'est pas du tout dans cet
état d'esprit 50 % sont pour une
adhésion profonde à l'Europe en gros
quoi 50 % sont pour un retrait donc un
président qui V sources vos sources de
de ça c'est quoi B les sources c'est les
différents sondages qu'on voit en fait
je pense qu'il y a plus une majorité
pour le
frxit à vrai dire en ce moment c'est 60
%. mais à certains moment ça se rétablit
disons qu'il y a pas quand même une
volonté aussi clairement exprimé qu'elle
était àangleterre en Grande-Bretagne
pour l'instant chez nous mais pour moi
c'est pas le problème parce que je vois
très bien ce qui va arriver si je
propose ça c'est qu'immédiatement on va
se diviser là-dessus et on va rien faire
or on a moi je n'aurais que quelques
semaines en tout début de mandat pour
prendre des orientations nouvelles donc
si vraiment ça marche pas je le
proposerai et pourquoi je ne propose pas
tout de suite parce que c'est notre
peuple n'est pas en état de voter dans
l'état actuel des choses il faut de
nouveau l'informer quelle est la
véritable nature des traités que nous
avons passés des engagements que nous
avons pris qu'est-ce qu'il y avait dans
mastrich je vous assure que il y a 70 %
des Français qui ne le savent pas et
pour je pourrais dire bien plus quelle
est la nature des traités quelle était
la nature du traité que le peuple a
refusé et que nous avons été acceptés à
Versailles et puis qu'elle est aussi la
nature des traités mondiaux j'ai besoin
de voir aussi de de d'expliquer et
j'appelle fortement tous mes concurrents
faire la même chose que moi la nature de
la dette qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
dette quelle est sa structure et comment
peut-on en sortir sans rembourser
pendant 80 ans ce que nous sommes
incapables de rembourcer puisque nous ne
produisons plus rien sauf des Ares que
nous vendons à des pays avant de le 2
ans avant de leur faire la guerre voilà
et et les avions avec le brevet de de de
donc donc la dette on va en faire quoi
votre lecture de la dette alors sur la
structure de la dette donc j'ai dit que
je voulais reprendre une une
certaine comment je devrais dire je dois
prendre de nouveau une posture
politique que la France doit avoir elle
ne l'a pas et c'est très préjudiciable
donc
reprendre mes aises politiques et je
dois reprendre des aises euh sur un plan
économique et financier et pour cela je
serais certainement amené bon puisqu'on
parle de l'Europe peut-être à ne pas
payer totalement
euh ce que je la France paye tous les
ans mais à cher euh écoutez même pas
elle est on ne retrouve même pas au
niveau de
l'agriculture ce que nous y le chiffre
exag pas je suis en train de comme je le
disais rappelez-moi rappelez-moi le PIB
français 2 millions 2 millions 2
millions de millions 200000 200000 EUR
j'ai pas compris
euh c'est 200li 200000 €
non bon écoutez les chiffres je vais
vous les donner moi j'ai une
philosophie200 milliardsen 2200
milliards c'est ex 200 milliards oui et
on a pe pr det la dette française c'est
combien
c'est à peu près de la même c'est-à-dire
qu'on a 99 % du PIB qui est gagé par la
dette en gros 96 97 % voilà donc dans
ces conditions je ne peux rien faire je
n'ai aucune marge de manœuvre est-ce que
vous connaissez le FESF le MES FESF non
le fond de stabilité européen pour les
banques oui alors ça par contre ça
pourrait me parler c'est-à-dire que
j'imagine que c'est le fond qui permet
euh de d'intervenir lorsqu'une banque
est en difficulté en faisant intervenir
massivement euh les banques la banque
européenne ou les états c'est les États
qui doivent cotiser au pot pour
renflouer une banque voilà nous l'avons
déjà fait et euh ceux pour qui nous
l'avons fait ne nous en onons pas été
très reconnaissants si j'en juge par les
profits de BNP ou de parisas il n'est
même pas euh capable de donner un coup
de main aujourd'hui ne serait-ce que
pour installer une petite entreprise une
grande ou même pour donner un coup de
main pour essayer de sauver ceux qui
veulent être encore dans l'agriculture
donc ça aussi c'est un des éléments sur
lequel euh il va falloir revoir
entièrement la politique et vous êtes
vous êtes penché est-ce que vous avez
planché sur la séparation des banques
d'affaires et des banques de détail
alors nous sommes en train d'y
travailler puisque j'ai la chance de
voir venir à moi un certain nombre à la
fois d'économistes mais même de
banquiers et euh et ça tombe bien il y
en a un qui est un banquier d'affaires
et et et l'autre qui est plutôt bon
banquier tel qu'on l'entendait
traditionnellement nous sommes en train
de préparer de voir ce qui peut-être
proposé je crois qu'on ne peut plus euh
et là l'état suffisamment d'autorité à
mon avis pour le faire nous ne nous en
savons plus laisser les
banques
d'affaires s'engager dans n'importe quoi
sans aucune demande sans aucune sans
aucune étude d'impact préalable sur ce
que ça donnera donc là aussi je dois
agir et ça je dois agir dans les
premières semaines de mon mandat si je
vous dis to big to fail ça vous fait
penser à
quoi je ne sais pas trop gros pour
tomber quand on parle d'une banque si tu
si une banque d'affaires tombe par effet
domino elle fait plier ses ses collègues
bancaires ses ses autres partenaires
bancaires ou les autres banques oui mais
je connais effectivement lorsque vous
l'exprimez comme ça mais je pense qu'on
va devoir sortir de ce
chantage euh je pense que Dar c'est très
bien c'est ce qui pourrait fort bien se
produire avec la Deutch Bank si les
renseignements son exa euh on dit que ça
a été retardé bon on le tient bon
écoutez après tout si une grande banque
s'écroule et bien on verra bien si
toutes les grandes banques s'écroulent
et bien on verra aussi je pense qu'elle
seouleront peut-être pas toutes en même
temps il est possible quand même qu'il y
ait un ultime accord qui soit passé
entre les pays je pense en Europe euh
les pays les principaux aux pays qui
sont tous commême très endettés pour
essayer de sauver ce qui peut l'être
mais après tout regardez ce qui s'est
passé aux États-Unis euh
euh il y a pas eu de mort si il y a eu
beaucoup de morts des pauvres des
Misérables beaucoup plus de visire mais
je crois qu'il y a un tel
éclaircissement à apportter euh une
telle lisibilité nouvelle à apportter
sur la politique monétaire et sur la
place de la finance aujourd'hui dans le
monde que il va bien y avoir des
accidents et bien si une banque
s'écroule et bien il faudra revoir le
système et si les banques s'écroulent il
va bien falloir quand même remonter
autre chose ce qui va ce que aujourd'hui
ne marche plus sur sur le le système
financier est-ce que vous êtes pour ou
contre ou qu'estce quelles sont les
mesures que vous proposez pour réguler
contrôler est-ce que vous êtes comme
dans le système nucléaire àorter un
protocole de
sécurité de sur les employés je je je
fais ù comme comme sur le les pilotes
les pilotes ou les employés dans le
nucléaire passent un certain nombre de
contrôles de santé pour savoir s'ils
prennent des stupéfiants est-ce que vous
vous êtes pour le le même contrôle pour
le personnel qui gère des milliards pour
nous parce que le les banques d'affaires
doivent être au même niveau que le la
Sûreté Nucléaire ah totalement parce que
les conséquences sont tout aussi
redoutables et on le verrait si
malheureusement toutes les banques
s'effondrai les banques d'affaires V
pour la fonction présidentielle est-ce
que vous êtes pour ah oui oui moi je
suis pour me soumettre à tous les vous
fait passer un test de stupéfiant tout
de suite maintenant vous êtes d'accord
tout à fait d'accord c'est même je pense
que ça serait même une des précautions
au lieu de dire tant de choses qui n'ont
aucun sens une des premières choses à
faire oui complètement d'accord
euh sur cette transparence est-ce que
vous avez un casier judiciaire à ma
connaissance non le seul avatar que j'ai
eu c'est un retrait de permis de une
annulation de permis de conduire
d'ailleurs pas pouritesse excessive
comment motif le motif c'était une série
de petites de de de petites peines que
j'avais un peu négligé je dois dire un
point parci un point par là mais
c'est-à-dire du 63 à l'heure au lieu de
de 60 du 54 au lieu du
6 voilà j'ai eu il faut dire la vérité
j'ai eu euh dans des temps ultérieurs
dans des temps vassés euh fait du
j'étais pris deux fois dans un radar à
l'allée et au retour d'ailleurs qui est
très connu euh juste avant à pay C
payorade à 172 kmh c'est entre sur la
quatre voies entre Bayonne entre Bayonne
et et bordeau retenu 172 oui mais à
l'époque on ne retirait pas le permis
immédiatement faisaitt dans l'infraction
puis vous payez l'amande et il y avait
même pas de de retrait automatique
c'était 72 au lieu de combien 110 C
c'était 130 c'était 130 130 je l'ai fait
à l'allée et au retour tellement j'avais
oublié donc c'est un c'est un délit de
grande vitesse quand même maintenant ah
oui c'était un délit là j'aurais eu le
permis pulvérisé c'estàdire retiré sur
le ch peut-être de la prison non
euh de la prison oui je crois pas que ce
soit pass possible peut-être c'est
possible c'est possible non mais c'est
pour vous dire je vais être clair mais
euh lorsqu'on m'a retiré le permis ce
n'était pas du tout sur des fautes comme
celle-là parce qu'il y avait eu l'énorme
travail qui a été conduit sur la réforme
du permis et notamment sur le fait qu'on
pouvait annuler le permis de conduire
parce que jusque-là le permis vous
l'aviez pour toute la vie or lorsqu'on a
fait cette réforme on a quand même mis
des règles du jeu beaucoup trop dur à
mon avis je l'ai vu parce que 30 mois de
retrait de permis pour moi ça était très
difficile mais j'ai trouvé un copain qui
m'a conduit et seulement j'ai découvert
à cette époque làà que il y a 2 millions
et demi de nos compatriotes qui
conduisent sans permis et sans assurance
ils peuvent pas avoir d'assurance
puisils ont pas de permis alors si
jamais vous tombez en face d'eux votre
vie est écroulée et vous quand vous
roulez à 172 km/h sur quelqu'un il y a
un proverbe égyptien qui dit un homme
pressé est un homme déjà mort
oui mais bon revenons revenons à NS
moutons vous avez pas de casier
judiciire il y a 25 ans il y a 30 ans et
à l'époque c'était pas je me faisais
doubler à ces vitesses là mais bon
c'était pas non plus tous les jours
c'est quand j'avais pris un peu de
retard maintenant on le fait plus je
n'ai pas eu un seul excès un seul délit
de grande vitesse depuis dans votre
équipe dans votre équipe est-ce que vous
avez des gens qui ont fait de la prison
ont entraîné dans des affaires non non
euh AUC par contre j'ai parmi des parmi
mes amis
euh quelques personnes qui en ont fait
et que j'essayie de faire travailler
bénévolement chez moi mais plutôt dans
le but de les réinsérer lorsque je fais
le les travaux de nettoyage l'été à la
maison sur la ferme familiale ils sont
très heureux de venir d'ailleurs le me
dit je viens plus parce que chez toi
c'est c'est j'ai fait la haute sécurité
à à freine mais chez toi c'est c'est
pire que qu'akayan autre fois le le
rythme que tu nous impos est
insupportable comment vous expliquez
qu'il y a autant d'affaires dans le
milieu politique mais parce que il y a
une iresonsabilité totale qui y règne
premièrement deuxièmement c'est que nous
n'avons plus aucun pouvoir nous avons
les apparences du pouvoir nous avons
l'apparat du pouvoir mais nous n'avons
plus le pouvoir politique au nom du
peuple tel qu'on peut l'imaginer qui
détient ce
pouvoir la
puissance financière qui n'est plus
d'ailleurs au service de l'homme mais
qui est uniquement au service de la
spéculation et qui a toute organisé avec
la haute administration pour prendre en
main et le monde politique et le monde
de la haute fonction
publique
nationale que vous comptez faire pour is
télvisionion et la télévision 70 %
qu'est-ce que vous comptez faire pour
responsabiliser la vie
politique on l'a fait comme en Corée du
Nord ou on l'a fait à la française non
je pense qu'il faut faire à la française
c'est ce que je vais annoncer dans
mon dans mon projet bon je prenons des
exemples très simples un parlementaire
parce que c'est là que ça commence les
élus locaux ne sont pas tellement mis en
cause pas de corruption chez chez les
élus locaux il va y en avoir beaucoup
maintenant avec le nouveau dispositif
qui recrée des machines irresponsables
c'està-dire que lorsque vous remettez s
communes ensemble dans une grande
intercommunalité reliant regroupant
plusieurs centaines de milliers
d'hectares avec des enjeux
considérables sur des bassins de vie qui
n'ont jamais travaillé ensemble n'ont
pas eu de relations vous mettez là un
président qui sera un vieux sénateur ou
un vieux député flanqué de 10 ou 15
vice-présidents qui seront payés comme
des conseillers départementaux pour que
ça marche mais euh qui n'auront pas
accès aux affaires les affaires ce sera
un directeur général des services comme
on sait si bien le faire en France et un
directeur de cabinet qui auront la
responsabilité donc très vite vous allez
voir d'ici 2 ou 3 ans venir des pots de
vin ou des scandales parce que on aura
donneré un tel plutôt qu'à un tel et que
l'appel d'offre n'aura pas été très
précis alors qu'est-ce que je fais au
niveau national donc pour l'instant il y
a pas de trop gros scandale sur
les sur les élus
territoriaux c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
que je veux abroger toutes les trois
lois qui ont été faites sur les
territoires mais nous aurons peut-être
l'occasion d'y revenir de dire pourquoi
euh un député qui est battu il est sur
un mandat de 5 ans il ne se représente
plus à aucune élection pendant 5 ans il
faut redonner de l'honneur et de la
dignité ce que M dit qui passe devant
les juges comment j'ai pas compris là
non je veux dire
que il en aura beaucoup au mois de je
prochain un député battu aux élections
législatives moi je vous parle d'un
député la main dans le sac un un
ministre la main dans le sac non mais je
voulais essayer de de faire le
raisonnement pour arriver au ministre à
le mainre dans le sac parce que le
ministre à le mainre dans le sac dans
l'état actuel des choses c'est
impossible d'arrêter parce que c'est
précisément ce qui qui permet au système
de continuer à fonctionner il faut
attraper de temps en temps un ministre M
dans le sac il faut attraper de temps en
temps un grand patron la m dans le sac
le pendre haut et court devant la place
publique pour faire peur aux autres pour
qu'il continue à fonctionner sans
histoire dans le système et en même
temps rassurer l'opinion pour montrer
que personne n'est à l'abri mais c'est
millimétré c'est tout à fait calculé et
nous n'y sommes pour rien alors ça
continuera à se produire parce que tant
qu'on permet aux hommes politiques euh
ou au chefs d'entreprise ou aux grands
journalistes d'aller mettre quelques
économies au Luxembourg ou euh en Suisse
c'est trop couru maintenant mais enfin
il y a les îes vierges on peut aller
dans beaucoup de domaines et bien ça
arrivera toujours voilà combien vous
gagnez vous moi je suis j'arrive plus à
5000 € j'étais à 5300 5400 j'ai une
petite baisse et je ne sais pas pourquoi
mensuel net en tant que député et à quoi
s'ajoute 9000 € payé par l'Assemblée
nationale pour payer mes trois attachés
parlementaires normalement mais j'en ai
eu jusqu'à h donc vous voyez que ça fait
quand même beaucoup de monde parce que
c'est nécessaire j'ai la plus grande
circonscription de France avec des
Basques des Bernis qui veulent se
séparer depuis au moins MOS 15 ans euh
et puis j'ai choisi d'être aussi euh
libre c'est-à-dire de siéger un député
indépendant à l'Assemblée ce qui fait
que je n'ai aucun appui de groupe je
n'ai aucun
préparateur personne je suis obligé de
faire avec des bénévoles qui m'aiment
bien qui travaill là mais c'est pas la
même le même r qu'estce que qu'est-ce
que vous pensez du jugement de Christine
Lagarde ah moi je pense qu'il est
totalement
justifié moi j'ai eu depuis le début de
elle est responsable mais pas coupable
ah non elle est responsable et
coupable écoutez quand on est à ce
niveau-là et qu'on exonè qu'on laisse
passer qu'on ferme les yeux sur une
affaire dont il est quandême de
notoriété publique que que Bernard tapi
quand même pas tout à fait enfin est
quand même très très très trouble dans
cette affaire euh que cela fait des
heures de débat à la Commission de
finances d'assemblée nationale dans
laquelle François baayerou à l'époque
s'est beaucoup engagé euh on savait très
bien que on couvrait un délit Christine
Lagarde était ministre à ce moment-là
euh il suffisait qu'elle dise non le
problème c'est qu'elle n'a pas dit nom à
Sarkozi voilà donc elle est coupable et
elle est responsable parce qu'elle
savait ce qu'elle faisait donc pour moi
il y a pas de problème
il faut Svir mais je voulais revenir à
mon pas fini qu'est-ce que vous pensez
de la gifle de Manuel Vals par un gamin
de 19 ans en Bretagne alors si vous
voulez sur un plan sur le plan des
grands principes c'est pas bon c'est pas
est-ce qu' un béarnaet qui se prend une
gifle par un gamin de 19 ans qu'est-ce
que fait le béarnet et bien le béarnet
il regarde le gamin dans les yeux et il
lui dit euh écoute mon vieu
bravo tu es un mec courageux maintenant
si tu voulais bien m'expliquer pourquoi
tu m'as mis la
giifle je serais content et je
demanderai au garde de s'écarter voilà
parce que ça c'est une forme d'honneur
et de dignité alors la gifle on peut
discuter mais dans un vous condamnez ça
vous condamnez est-ce que vous le
condamnez le gamin non pas du tout non
parce qu'on est dans un système
démocratique et on ne peut pas à fois à
la fois s'afficher comme un homme proche
du peuple dire moi je suis proche du
peuple moi je parle du peuple je suis
très proche de lui et et se mettre à se
lamenter si on prend une gifle bien moi
il m'est arrivé d'en prendre et bien
j'ai regardé si c'était une Giffre mal
venue je veux dire travailler étudier
dans le sens de de de de nuire et cetera
mais je crois que dans le cas présent à
19 ans c'est plôt une gaffe
d'exaspération et j'avais dit d'ailleurs
à Gif insurrectionnel c'est ça voilà
insurrectionnel c'est le terme et
j'avais dit d'ailleurs à Manuel Vals euh
tu verras avec ce que tu fais avec ton
autisme notamment sur la réforme
territorial qui nous aené là où nous
sommes je lui dit tu prendras des gifles
je pensais pas aussi bien dire je lui
avais d'ailleurs prédit que Macron
allait le déboulonner à moins de 2 ans
euh quand j'ai vu arriver Macron non
c'est une giifle insurrectionnelle
j'avais pas trouvé le terme moi elle me
choque pas du tout et moi j'ai pris des
chifffles et des crachats dans la figure
plus d'une fois j'ai pris je ne sais
combien de fois des œufs pourris je ne
me suis jamais plain parce qu'après tout
personne ne vous amène à faire de la
politique vous en faites si vous voulez
alors ensuite bon qu'on respecte si on
peut l'intégrité physique de façon ne
pas détruire enti avant quelqu'un mais
ne chiffre çaa jamais tué personne au
contraire c'est très
revigourant on va parler
d'écologie votre programme il aborde
l'écologie comment il aborde l'écologie
d'une manière
responsable mais après avoir d'abord
expliqué au peuple de quoi on parle
est-ce qu'il s'agit oui ou non de
prendre en charge de nouveau et dans ce
monde complexe et c'est si difficile à
faire la terre et notre planète d'
manière responsable où est-ce qu'il
s'agit comme nous le faisons depuis 40
ans de faire semblant s'il s'agit de
faire semblant moi je ne joue pas à ce
jeu-à le
WWF moi si vous voulez je les connais
bien
c'est un des bras armé de la
spéculation qui nous détruit
littéralement aujourd'hui vous avez des
preuves ah complètement j'ai des preuves
et d'ailleurs meilleur des ce que je dis
ceci je me suis j'ai eu un très violent
accrochage avec le président national du
WWF qui était invité un grand de pome à
Paris et que j'ai pris à Paris les
archives et que j'ai pris à l'Assemblée
nationale il y a les archives à Lina
j'ai pas beaucoup d' j'en ai pas mal
d'archivalina d'ailleurs et qui montre
mais il n'a pas été capable de me
répondre et pourquoi je je dis cela tout
simplement parce que lorsque le
WWF a été mis sur pied à l'époque par de
frères hollandais ils ont vu tout ce qu'
tout le tout l'argent qu'il y avait à se
faire sur
euh des produits qui n'avaient pas
encore été tarifés à qui on avait pas
donné une valeur marchande parmi eux la
nature euh maintenant on peut acheter du
gaz carbonique bientôt de l'oxygène et
cetera et cetera et la beauté des
montagne la beauté d'un ours la beauté
d'un lion la beauté de ceci donc on a
décidé mais le problème c'est que ces
hommes déjà moi je les ai pas trouvé
très intéressants l' était à la tête
pour ou contre l'ours dans les Pyrénées
euh j'étais pour parce que au fond mon
père berger qu' avait côtoyé beaucoup
plus que moi moi je l'ai côtoyé
quelquefis j'avais le cœur qui explosait
dans ma poitrine euh parce que j'étais
petit et que j'avais très très peur
lorsque lesbreui montait littéralement
sur le tas de tes qui te servait de
refuge et que mon père sortait
euh un quart d'heure après toujours
pareil en disant euh il était fou de
rage il cumé l'ours lu en avait pris
deux ou trois et puis il y avait les
avortements qui allaiit suivre pendant
tout l'hiver et sur le coup il était F
de rage et puis après il me rassurit et
lui aussi il disait ben qu'est-ce que tu
veux il fait partie de du règne animal
il a sa place mais il ferait mieux de se
mettre au travail lui aussi au lieu de
toujours venir me taper me taxer moi
donc je je partais pas sur un a priori
défavorable mon père n'aimait pas les
ours mais il ne voulait pas leur
disparition il n'a jamais utilisé de
fusil ni de sttiquinine contrairement à
beaucoup d'autres qui l'ont fait lorsque
le parc national des Pyrenées s'est
construit ce s fait sans penser à
dédommager les dégâts de ceux qui
avaient des brebis emportés ce qui se
fait pendant 10 ou 15 ans c'est là que
beaucoup d' sont morts non pas sous les
balles mais s la
stgline pouri à moitié dévoré que le BSE
laisse pour revenir la PR on va passer
sur le nucléaire qu'est-ce qu'on fait
avec le nucléaire moi je pense que sur
le nucléaire il faut lever le pied
maintenant parce que pour beaucoup de
raisons
euh d'abord
euh nous ne gérons absolument pas depuis
le début les déchets là nous venons de
prendre la décision d'aller en errer je
ne sais combien de de tonnes pour une
trentaine une quarantaine d'années avec
comme se le garantie si ça va pas on les
redéterrera présenter comme ça et voter
comme ça à l'Assemblée hein donc on va
les mettre ces déchets alors on a aucune
garantie on sait pas combien de temps il
reste activé combien de temps il reste
et qu'est-ce qui va se passer si jamais
il se produit un phénomène à cet
endroit-là de la mer bon deuxièmement
les Français et pas que les Français d'
manière généraleopinion occidentale qui
a été très favorable et moi aussi je
l'ai été en son temps
euh à peur d'abord parce qu'il y a eu
euh le drame de de pays de de de
l'est-moi tchernoby que j'ai visité et
quand on visite tchernoby on a pas
besoin d'y revenir de fois pour
comprendre quand vous voyez des
bonhommes qu'on promènent sur une boîte
qui n'ont ni bras ni jambes et comme
tête un petit renflement et que le frère
promène sur une boîte vous comprenez et
quand vous allez aux alentours moi
j'étais eu la chance d'aller très loin
parce que j'étais avec deares
spécialistes il m'avit bien équipé vous
voyez la mort c'est la mort c'est
terrifiant
terrifiant pour remplacer ça le Japon ça
fait peur donc qu'est-ce qu'on
fait et bien il faut trouver euh des
sources de substitution euh moi j'ai
beaucoup pour vous fait d'abord pour les
déchets ah pour déchets justement je
suis en train de de réfléchir sur le
sujet personne n'a la solution et moi je
ne l'ai pas pour l'instant non plus
parce qu'il faudrait savoir comment
d'abord on désactive combien ça va nous
coûter ah c'est cher très cher mais
excusez-moi mais j'ai encore un moin
pour détailler mon projet je je le ferai
connaître parce que c'est un des
éléments essentiel parce que moi je je
veux en finir avec les cops 21 22 23 qui
sont une une immense hypocrisie
j'inviterai à Paris un petit club de
pays qui sont sur la même longueur
d'onde que la France que moi pour et
vous pressentez qui comment vous
pressentez qui sur le le nucléaire dans
le dans le même courant que
vous je pressends peut-être l'Allemagne
parce qu'elle a quand même fait des
efforts c'est pas bon très bien venu
parce qu'elle a reouvert des mines de
charbon c'est pas non plus ce qu'on
avait à faire de mieux mais au moins a a
fait de très gros efforts les pays
nordiques qui ont quand même une une
vision peut-être des pays tels que
l'Australie qui ont été
fortement justement impactés par nos ESS
nucléairire et tout ce qui s'est passé
autour certainement pas dans un premier
temps les Américains peut-être les
Japonais parce que eux ils savent de
quoi ils parlent ils sont dans la
recherche de solutions comme nous sur
l'alimentation vos positions sur le v
isme sur le fait de diminuer sa
consommation de
viande sur peut-être les conditions
d'élevage et d'abattage ah oui là il y a
beaucoup à faire alors vous avez dans
votre région eu un abattoir qui s'est
fait un petit peu étrier par L214 je
crois bien non oui il se fait totalement
étrier et je suis pas étranger
d'ailleurs à son sauvetage parce que
j'estimais qu'il était absolument
indispensable pour le territoire euh
ceci
étant je je j'apprécie assez modérément
d'ailleurs l'attitude de de
l'association en question pourquoi parce
que
elle se prend elle désigne abdominan des
individus je pense que c'est beaucoup
plus le système qu'il faudrait attaquer
bille en tête et maintenant elle a
l'expérience je crois qu'elle a une
petite unité d'une douzaine de personnes
a démarré très modestement c'est le
système qu'il faut attaquer là dans le
cas d'espèce que vous me signalez je
connais les deux personnes ces deux
garçons de 20 ans et 21 ans ils ne sont
il n'était même pas euh bouché dans cet
avattoir comme c'était la semaine de de
de pâqu juste avant pâqu euh ils ont été
donné un coup de main parce qu'ils
devaient abattre tous les deux c'est des
chiffres monstrueux mais 800 ou 900
agnaux par jour 21 ans et en même temps
il son occupé de l'exploitation
familiale parce que les bouchers de
l'abattoir étaient complètement débordés
quand vous avez 21s 21 ans vous imaginez
qu'au bout d'un
moment c'est complètement abrutissant
d'abattre moi j'ai abattu des animaux
donc je sais ce que c'est c'est je peux
vous dire que vous le faites mais ça
vous prend une saqué tension nerveuse
mais lorsque vous devez en faire 800 par
jour vous ne vous ne maîtrisez rien
qu'en plus vous allez traire le troupeau
en rentrant à Minuit le soir pour
repartir à 5h du matin ça n'a aucun sens
donc on a brisé ces deux gamins à qui
j'ai parlé d'ut on parlit l'un on l'a
sauvé du suicide c'est évident donc je
dis que pour une
association qui se qui à fort quand je
mange je devrais dire à fort capital
humanitaire il faut rectifier un petit
peu à mon avis c'est pas les hommes
c'est le système et il faut s'en prendre
au système et le le dénoncer beaucoup
plus violemment parce que c'est le
système productiviste à outrance au cou
le plus bas qui impose effectivement de
tels comportements qui sont absolument
euh scandaleux ça c'est un des éléments
sur lequels je travaillerit beaucoup on
na pas besoin de faire subir un tel
traitement aux animaux pour pour contre
le fait que les abattoirs soient
entièrement monitorés par des caméras
oui je préféreris que ce soit basé sur
la
responsabilité parce que le fait d'être
monitoré par les caméras
induit comment je devrais dire stress
supplémentaire que vous avez déjà parce
que quand vous tuez un animal vous êtes
déjà sous tension hein vous savez
euh bon qu'on passe par une période
intermédiaire pour redonner confiance et
pour trouver d'autres solutions pour
pourquoi pas je crois pas que ça puisse
être quand on fait un métier à haut
risque je pense pas que ça puisse être
la solution est-ce qu'on peut demander
ça n'a rien à voir mais je vais choquer
en disant ça est-ce qu'on peut demander
à un très grand professeur qui opère à
cœur ouvert de se faire filmer en
permanence voou sont filmés en
permanence en général c'est même
retransmis sur internet à l'ut bout du
monde pour que les Indiens puissent se
former en même temps oui mais il y en a
certains qui ne le font pas c'est pas
systématique non plus c'est bien dommage
certainement mais moi ce que je je base
beaucoup plus je je me base beaucoup
plus sur l'énorme capacité de
responsabilité dont nous sommes capables
VO la ferme des 1000 vaches qu'est-ce
qu'on en pense horreur absolue c'est la
déchéance c'est plus de la agriculture
les usines polluantes les usines
polluantes ah oui c'est du
même tout ça ben tout ça il faut trouver
des solutions d'abord parce que ça ne
sert à rien de dire est-ce que vous
ferez passer l'emploi avant l'écologie
ah ça dépend ça dépend des cas non pas
toujours non non non lorsque l'écologie
c'est-à-dire lorsque vraiment il y a un
risque avéré ou plus qu'un risque
c'est-à-dire un dommage réel pour la
nature et pour l'air que nous respirons
enfin pour la chlorophyle pour des
arbres non je pense pas que ça peut être
l'emploi à tout prix par contre je ne
veux pas qu'on raconte d'histoire comme
WWF qui fait payer les riches pollueurs
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de l'action de
si Shepard Paul
Watson vous savez le pirate des mers qui
coule des Batou japonais parce que ils
vont à la chasse à la bine là où il faut
pas bah écoutez euh
auond c'est pas c'est pas une mauvise
chose je crois que si euh si on laisse
tout faire et si personne n'a le courage
je pense que cet homme a quand même un
certain courage excusez-moi je conna que
fait 114 euh oui mais euh qu'est-ce que
vous voulez que je dise euh bateau il ne
part pas quand même à l'aventure il sait
de quoi il fait que il y a des hommes à
boir j'imagine il y a une très grosse
responsabilité il y a de très gros
capitaux qui sont engagés le le petit
abattoir de de Méon qui fonctionne avec
des bénévoles de 20 ans ou de 21 ans euh
c'est à la mor qu'ils étaient bénévoles
quand même comment ils étaient peut-être
pas bénévoles il touchaient peut-être un
peu la pièce non oui il touchait un peu
la pièce oui
certainement S comme une mesure par
rapport à ce que ça on va passer à la
géopolitique et à la
géostratégie vous avez fait un petit
séjour en
Syrie comment vous êtes parti là-bas qui
est-ce qui vous a approché vous avez
pris votre avion où votre correspondance
était où vous étiez combien dans l'avion
il y avait qui avec vous alors j'ai pris
l'av à rissi qu'est-ce qui vous a
approché alors c'est d'abord c'est c'est
moi qui cherchais euh à aller vraiment
en Syrie d'abord parce
que on voit pas les images d'Alep euh
vous avez fait comment pour rentrer en
contact avec le réseau syrien mais je je
vais le dire je vais le dire mais pour
moi ça ça raisonnait parce que j'ai
connu à 1990 et 1994 j'ai été à deux
reprises il y avait plus de mini Jup que
de que de savez de femmes voilées à
l'époque et c'était un pays qui m'avait
surpris parce que comme le Liban
d'ailleurs pratiquement les de tiers de
la population parlait français je n'en
revenais pas c'est un pays qui avait
l'air d'aller bien c'était pas Paris
mais c'était au moins largement Tunis
aujourd'hui vous avez été approché
comment alors c'est moi qui a pris
contact avec le l'association des
chrétiens d'Orient et je leur ai demandé
est-ce que par hasard comme l'an dernier
vous n'avez pas projeté un nouveau
voyage m'a dit ça tombe très bien il y
en a un dans 8 jours qui finance cette
association alors cette association est
financée d'abord par ses propres
euh par ses propres membres
euh qui ont bon sont quand même assez
modestes je pense qu'ils n'ont pas
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent dire je n'ai
pas fait une enqute payé votre billet
d'avion j'ai payé le billet d'avion
l'hébergement sur place l'hébergement
sur placetait pris par une association
qui s appelle
à quelque chose en fait c'est une
association locale don je m'étais fait
préciser les les donateurs c'est des
commerçants c'est la Chambre de commerce
de de Damas c'est voilà il y a divers
commerçants dont j'ai eu la liste euh
sommes assemblé clair le service d'ord
bien sûr est assuré par l'armée syrienne
est-ce que vous avez rencontré
des c'est pas des brimades mais est-ce
que vous on vous a empêché un petit peu
de faire ce que vous voulez ce que vous
vouliez sur place ou ah pas du tout
carte blanche à 100 j'ai pas eu du tout
l'impression bon ceci dit vous pouvez
pas non plus faire des des Mones de
merveilles parce que prix quand même
dans un dans un processus qui va à toute
vitesse qui va assez vite vous P parter
de
l'hôtel bon tout le monde est un peu sur
le pied de guerre encore j'ai trouvé
plus relâché cette dernière fois que
l'an dernier l'an dernier est-ce que la
DGSE a préparé votre voyage ah pas du
tout enfin pas à ma connaissance la DG
vous a contacté pour préparer votre
voyage ah pas du tout est-ce que vous
avez contacté le qu d'orset avant d'
aller pas du tout non non j'ai contacté
personne je quand j'ai j'ai pris les
dates et je suis parti avec mes deux
collègues de voyage et puis par contre
la DGSE ne vous a pas apporté une aide
logistique ou une une aide de perception
de votre voyage sur place vous député de
la République française non pas du tout
et on m'a rien demandé non la seule
chose que j'ai faite j'ai fait par
contre c'est j'ai fais une lettre au
président de l'Assemblée nationale en
disant que j'envisageais de me rendre en
Syrie de telle date à telle date parce
que ça c'est tout à fait norm quel a été
son retour j'ai pas de
retour vous étiez là-bas avec Thierry
Mariani c'est ça oui et qui d'autrre et
Monsieur
euh vite qui est euh député de
de euh du côté de Verdun si je me
souviens bien et qui est un qui est un
psychiatre qu'est-ce que donc votre
entretien avec bacharassade a duré
combien de temps oh 1 he et14 je crois
vous avez été prévenu combien de temps à
l'avance
ah on le savait avant de de partir moi
je savais que l'heure et le jour vous
saviez ah non pas l'heure et le jour
mais je savais qu'on verrait B cher à
laass on vous a prévenu combien de temps
avant de l'heure et du jour la veille la
veille à à
22h30 environ nous revenions d'halep et
nous sommes arrivés à Damas 223h bon moi
je pensais que ce serait certainement ce
jour-là mais l'horaire a été d'abord
annoncé à 8h du matin donc s levé pour
êre près 8h vous avez annoncé lors de
votre dernier passage médiatique dans On
n'est pas couché que vous aviez des
doutes sur le
bombardement les crimes de guerre de de
Bachar alAssad qu'est-ce qui vous ont
qu'est-ce qui vous conduit qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qui vous a poussé à avoir ce
raisonnement quels sont les les éléments
qui puissent étayer votre raisonnement
c'était des éléments qui étaient
intérieurs d'illeurs à mes deux voyages
c'est euh étant dans la commission des
finances je n'ai pas les tout à fait les
mêmes informations que mes collègues qui
sont dans la commission de défense mais
comme nous n'en avons pas beaucoup ni
l'un ni l'autre c'est les ventes d'armes
que nous continuons euh à euh sur lequel
nous donnons un visa j'étais très étonné
qu'on continue à à vendre des armes euh
notamment à l'Arabie Saoudite et
notamment au Qatar que nous avyons vendu
des armes à la Libye juste avant
d'attaquer kadfi très longtemps et des
armes massives qu'on est vendu des armes
à la Syrie jusqu'en 2009 qu'on est
suspendu en 2009 mais qu'on en estit
revendu de nouveau en 2011 je j'ai j'ai
souvent posé des questions à ce
niveau-là et sans parler celle que nous
vendons encore que nous avons encore
vendu cette année au Qatar et à l'Arabie
Saoudite j'ai trouvais que c'était assez
curieux et je me suis dit il faut quand
même que j'aille écouter que j'aille
voir un peu sur place donc j'avais des
doutes ensuite j'ai eu encore davantage
de doutes parce que je me serais attendu
à trouver une colonne de musulmans
modérés vêtus de blanc
euh pour dire voilà c'est cela que nous
soutenons j'ai vu
euh et là j'ai pu le voir puisque nous
avons eu un échange de roquettes d'une
colline à l'autre j'ai vu qu'il y avait
deux fronts mais je n'ai pas vu au
milieu des cavaliers blancs qui disaient
oh la paix la paix la paix non ça c'est
une grande supercherie
ensuite j'ai rencontré le maire d'halepe
donc je ne savais pas qu'il existait
d'ailleurs parce qu'on m'avait présenté
sur les studios de télévision en France
euh maire d'haleep est qui est maire
d'halep est comme moi je suis président
en titre de la Hongrie vous voyez si
vous voyez ce que je veux dire donc un
chiffon et on l'a présenté dans tous les
studios de télévision avec l'actuel
ministre de la défense alors que le
maire d'Alep existe il est maire et de
est et ouest les explications qu'il m'a
donné m'ont assez étonné c'était
peut-être le maire le maire il y avait
le maire occidental qui était chez nous
il y avait le le maire de Bachar
al-Assad qui était là-bas aussi
peut-être non non non non il était maire
depuis combien de temps depuis 5 ans le
maire officiel est maire depuis 5 ans on
vous l'a ditou vous l'avez vérifié
comment on vous l'a dit ou vous vous
l'avez vérifié nous l'avons rencontré
non vous l'avez vérifié c'est est-ce que
vous avez fait son pédigré avant de le
rencontrer c'est-à-dire est-ce que il y
avait des non mais il le remet le il il
vous le remet il remet qu il remet son
bédigré il dit il dit voilà comment
j'été l'umère voilà qu'est-ce que je
fais voilà quelles sont les actions
auxquelles j'ai été associé pendant
notamment toute la bataille d'ALP mais
mais le siège d'ALP aussi est-ce que
j'ai vu de mes propres yeux
c'est alors il ne le dit pas comme ça on
dit si on demande comme on était là et
moi je suis assez curieux et je pose des
questions que vous m'en posez
aujourd'hui c'est un homme que j'ai
trouvé assez convaincant il y a un autre
fait que j'ai trouvé qui m'a frappé j'ai
connu hélas l'Espagne franquiste
PCE que je peux dire
làdessus V parler de gunica de gunica
mais j'ai parlé de l'attitude des des
Espagnols lorsqu'il voyent
arriver un petit car ù ne seraitce que
quelques soldats de l'armée espagnole
plus forte raison des Guardi civiles des
gendarmes je peux vous dire que il s'en
allait il taillit la zone en vitess j'ai
vu la même chose en l'Union soviétique
ou dans les pays d'Union soviétique j'ai
vu la même chose au pays de pinoché je
voyais pas beaucoup d'amabilité par
contre ce qui m'a beaucoup surpris alors
pour dire que tout ça arrangé mais enfin
quand vous voyez sortir de l' des hommes
des
femmes couverts de poussière de tous les
âges de tous les âges mais aussi des des
hommes qui ont l'air d'avoir de savoir
ce que veut dire les chos qui
s'expriment remarquablement qui qui qui
viennent de nulle part qui se
réapproprie l'église qui se réapproprie
l'hôpital qui se
réapproprie un petit peu la ville qui
est dévastée et qui saute au coup des
militaires ça vous fait un drôle d'ffet
euh je crois en la conscience humaine la
conscience des peuple je crois qu'on
sauteute pas au coup de ceux qui vous
ont gazé d'utant que c'est une armée de
conscription contrairement àfanceù
aujourd'hui nous avons une amé euh de
métier je j'ai rarement vu ça alors
ensuite sur ce que m'a dit Bachar
alAssad je lui ai posé la question très
froidement et je lui ai dit j'observerai
le moindre de vos plissement Dieu je
l'ai dit j'ai mis du temps il a écouté
tout le monde a laiss faire et il m'a
répondu faire marer quand même non ah
non il ne se Mar les services les
services syriens sont réputés quand même
pour
préparer leur leur
personneloui
maisfin qu'est-ce que je devrais dire
revenons revenons non non non je veux
dire quandme mot là-dessus qu'est-ce qui
est le plus important aujourd'hui est-ce
que c'est toujours d'essayer de
d'éradiquer daesh et même Al-Qaïda qui
sont présents là-bas c'est très net ou
au contraire c'est pas important quel
est le seul qui aujourd'hui les a
vraiment en face jeer question est-ce
que vous pensez que les
occidentaux font passer la guerre pour
des crimes humanitaires du côté de
Bachar al-Assad et du côté occidental
pour sauver la démocratie pour les
petites filles c'est-à-dire que est-ce
qu'il y a pas un une double lecture des
bombardements en zonees civil
c'est-à-dire que quand l'Arabie Saoudite
bombarde au Yémen c'est pour sauver les
petites filles et que quand Bachar
al-Assad bombarde une zone on va dire
fortement à une forte avec une forte
densité urbaine c'est un crime contre
l'humanité est-ce qu'il y a pas une
double lecture une double perception
quand Yan MOX vous objecte que vous ne
reconnaissez pas les crimes de guerre de
Bachar al-Assad qu'est-ce que ça vous
fait ça m'étonne de la part de MOX je le
lui ai dit parce qu'il a écrit terreur
et il dit à peu près le contraire de ce
qu'il n'explique à la télévision dans ce
qu'il a dit moi je pense qu'il y a deux
lectures effectivement alors que c'est
la même lecture euh la guerre c'est sale
comment la guerre c'est dégueulasse
surtout qu'elle est très compliquée
là-bas qu'il est très difficile de faire
elle est religieuse
et inspiration religieuse c'est des des
chites qui sont encore un petit peu plus
chit avec une majorité sunnite dans le
pays
euh ils sont opposés à des sunites bon
ensuite c'est une guerre du gaz avant
tout ça c'est quelque chose que je
présumais parce que je voyais la
géographie comment elle était je voyaez
les efforts qu'avait fait le Qatar pour
traverser la Syrie pour pouvoir
rejoindre le ne pétrolier de de l'Égypte
de façon à pouvoir
alimenter la Turquie et surtout l'Europe
après le froid que nous avons eu avec
Poutine et euh bien
sûr sont vos solutions vous serez vous
serez président de la
République ce sera ce sera quoi vos
solution pour apaiser le conflit d'abord
je l'ai dit je le redis je vais retirer
immédiatement les l'armée française de
ces l'ensemble de ces sites parce que
nous n'avons plus rien à y faire
tellement c'est pourri même pas de force
d'interposition non on verra plus tard
mais il faut marquer un signe fort je
rouvre les ambassades parce que quand
même ce que m'ont dit beaucoup de
d'hommes et de femmes intellectuel il
m'ont dit enfin c'est bien beau votre
histoire mais vous nous quittez si vous
étiez si euh sûr du fait d'Assat mais
vous êtes au moins c'est de la
nonassistance c'est au minimum de la
nonassistance en personne en danger vous
auriez au moins pu recevoir nos leaders
et les garder vous aviez suffisamment
d'autorité la France si vous l'aviez
fait avec les Américains mais même tout
seul non vous fermez tout et vous partez
vous êtes dépenses Pilate parfait puis
ensuite vous donnez des leçons vous vous
êtes dans un état vous êtes en dessus
dessous lorsque vous avez l'affaire
Charlie abdo mais vous avez un point
d'impact nous nous sommes trouvés avec
500 points d'impact sur l'ensemble du
pays et une grande partie de l'exarmée
irakienne et libienne en face et je peux
vous dire c'était pas peu de choses et
nous regagnons le territoire et moi je
pense que ce qu'il faut c'est que la
Syrie se retourne de nouveau euh se
retrouve en liberté qu'ensuite on
organise des élections éventuelles
éventuellement je pense que s ne sera
pas battu je je vois vraiment un
enthousiasme autour de lui qui est
incroyable
ensuite je ne suis pas juge à la si par
contre je reg l'aspect de la je crains
que s'il y va euh je le crain s'il y va
il ne soit pas seul je pense qu'il y
aura des hauts dignitaires français qui
l'accompagneront ça j'eni à quiis
maintenant la conviction absolu tout
ceci n'a pas pu se faire sans que la
France sache voilà et la France a su la
France a au minimum couvert et la France
a même favorisé par la vente de ses
armes à tort et à
travers quoi favoriser quoi j'ai pas
bien compris favoriser quoi favoriser
quoi la France a favorisé quoi a
favorisé cet état de fait c'est-à-dire
euh le fait que Bachar ait pu
effectivement euh tirer sur le peuple
parce que à partir du moment où il y a
eu le printemps arabe auquel j'ai cru
moi-même
très
rapidement on sait maintenant que ces
mouvements qui étent des mouvements je
sincère mais ont été instrumentalisé par
euh bien Al-Qaïda et puis bon le comment
vous les appeler là les les les fux
furieux n ch maintenant enfin le le leé
islamique l'État islamique voilà et euh
vous avez vu ce que ça donnait en
Tunisie et même en Égypte où on aorent
Fabius dit Jabal nostra fait du bon
boulot c'est faux il est totalement avec
les forces c'est c'est c'est Al-Qaïda
c'est Al-Qaïda version syrienne c'est
totalement faux je m'inscris en faux
contre cela ils sont contre l'armée
syrienne là aujourd'hui c'est pas une
affaire de gazage c'est une affaire de
voir si on met un terme ou pas aux
exactions de de ces tueurs et si on
récupère le territoire de la Syrie
ensuite qu'on y organise des élections
qu'on traduisent Bachar al-Assad devant
le tribunal de la Hae là on verra ce que
je dis simplement c'est que peut-être
monsieur Fabius fera parti aussi de ceux
qui
seront convoqués à l'é c'est des mots
lourds oui
mais ce que je souhaiterais c'est que
j'ai pas pu le dire l'autre soir parce
qu'on a coupé le morceau sur lequel je
le disait j'espère que on va enfin
ouvrir la véritable campagne
présidentielle en France on va pas se
contenter de d'observer se mercenaire
d'un côté se mercenaire de l'autre ou ou
plutôt euh sur mur euh cette victime et
il y en a qu'un qu'on laisse vivant
voilà ils disent tous la même chose ils
ne disent rien est-ce qu'on va oui ou
non s'emparer de ce problème qui est une
question de vie ou de mort pour
l'humanité aujourd'hui au point
d'avancement où nous en sommes o est-ce
qu'on continue à faire semblant moi je
veux que Monsieur Fillon se positionne
je veux que le candidat des socialistes
se positionne dise ce qu'il sait ou ce
qu'il ne sait pas qu'il prenneent des
engagements et qu'ils disent comme moi
devant une télé je suis devant une
caméra de télévision face à quelqu'un
qui m' interterview ce qu'il en est et
je veux que Monsieur Macron Monsieur
Mélenchon tout le monde parle voilà
qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec Trump mais
avec Trump on n pas tellement le choix
il a été élu président des États-Unis
bon au Mandre des choses ce serait
peut-être de continuer à faire comme
s'il n'était rien de de choses l'une où
on respecte où on dit que le suffrage
universel existe encore même si aux
États-Unis j'en convient il est bien
compliqué c'est pas forcément celui qui
a le plus de voix qui gagne mais
euh je crois que le fait de dire qu'il
s'enprend à l'Europe
parce qu'il dit que l'Europe ne va pas
tenir c'est un peu léger regardez de
quelle manière nous l'avons considéré de
quelle manière nous le traitons depuis 1
an et demi qu'il est candidat nous
av'avons pas de mot assez dur et puis
nous continuons moi je pense que il va
pas de nous faire de cadeau mais qui en
ferait à sa place même si le personnage
peut prêter à caution il a été élu et
maintenant il est président des
États-Unis alors moi par contre ce que
je fais si je suis de mon élection
je prendrai contact avec lui dès que
possible ce sera peut-être pas ma
première rencontre mais j'ai besoin de
savoir si je peux travailler avec cet
homme et son équipe représentant les
États-Unis d'Amérique oui ou non je vais
très vite le savoir votre lecture sur
son protectionnisme mais c'est-à-dire
c'est un peu la réponse qu'il apporte à
un peuple
exaspéré parce que c'est un peuple qui
n'a aucune réponse qui n'a pas confiance
en l'establishement qui s'appauvrit il y
a un système de popérisation
considérable aux États-Unis parce que
ils vivent à la puissance 10 ce que nous
vivons déjà c'est-à-dire le le le le
requête des des des des grandes
puissance de de spéculation qui
conduisent à
à les producteurs quels qu'ils soi à
produire au plus bas prix les américains
n'étaient pas forcément habitués à ça et
pour eux c'est c'est complètement
insupportable qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec
Poutine avec Poutine je pense que c'est
euh le patron enfin c'est le président
élu et réélu même si les conditions ont
été un peu
abantesque d'un grand pays la Russie qui
a toujours pesé sur le monde on ne peut
pas rester sans relation avec Poutine
Poutine je pense représente une Russie
BL laissé une une Russie
postsoviétique qui a eu le sentiment de
constituer une grande puissance mondiale
qui maintenant s'est senti méprisé des
années durant et je pense que Poutine
est un peu dans la gonflette il en fait
un peu beaucoup mais on lui donne aussi
beaucoup d'occasions de le faire quand
on lui quand on voit qu'il devient le
patron du gaz et qu'on continue à le
traiter comme le dernier des des des des
des il faut pas s'étonner qu' n le fasse
payer non je pense que la France doit
être porteuse deun message fort c'est la
raison pour laquelle moi je retire les
troupes mais je relance immédiatement la
diplomatie française qui à qui il est
arrivé d'être génial dans l'histoire il
faut retrouver la grande diplomatie
française parce qu'elle a un
savoir-faire et elle a un art avec une
mission c'est de repréparer de la paix
nous faut que nous proposions de nouveau
concept de la paix moi je suis un
amoureux des processus de paix le France
CFA oh je pense qu'il faudra abandonner
cette histoire là c'est France Afrique
c'est
ça 70 ans ça n'a généré que du du
malheur et je crois qu'il faut j'ai un
grand projet pour l'Afrique je veux
intégrer l'Afrique dans mon projet ça
c'est une formidable aventure que je
propose parce que ce continent aura 800
millions de jeunes dans 25 ans d'ici et
il y a encore beaucoup de francophonie
même si elle s'éteint de plus en plus
parce que nous ne faisons plus rien
d'ailleurs je veux rouvrir partout des
ambassade qui soit l'argent que je vais
récupérer des troupes qui ne seront plus
sur les théâtres d'opération je les
investis immédiatement là-dessus qu'on
reouvre aussi euh des lieux où on
apprend le français euh et partout où la
France pourra faire passer l'influence
de sa langue qui est une langue
d'indépendance de liberté et faire
passer son concept d'humanité et de
remonter en civilisation de remonter en
civilisation je le ferai et la France a
un très grand rôle à jouer pour sauver
le monde de l'explosion sijin ping
comment le président
chinois
c'est pour pour moi c'est une énigme
c'est aussi la la preuve de ce que peut
ce très grand peuple allié le
communisme le le plus enfin comment je
dirais
euh le plus communiste si je puis dire
aujourd'hui
à comment à l'utilisation des dernières
méthodes spéculatives les plus élaborées
euh acheter
ou
exproprier partout euh se rendre maître
d'une grande partie de la planète et de
la plupart des richesses mais c'est de
la politique
véritablement
très efficace certainement pour son pays
et très dangereuse pour l'avenir moi je
pense que par contre nous ne sommes pas
assez en observation devant ce phénomène
et que là on lae se faire qu'est-ce que
la France fera avec la guerre
commerciale qui est en train de se
profiler devant
nous entre la Chine et les États-Unis
oui oui oui oui mais la France doit
d'abord retrouver des marges politiques
et financières je le disais nous sommes
un grand pays c'est pas parce que on n
pas un milliard et demi de personnes qu'
est pas un grand pays Israël en a 6
millions personnes jamais dit que
c'était un petit pays c'est la volonté
qui compte donc je crois que d'abord
nous devons recommencer à nous
reconstruire nous n'avons pas
d'agriculture il faut reconstruire une
agriculture et une agriculture propre à
la dimension humaine conduite par des
hommes qui ne démarrent pas leur vie
archiandté et qui puissent faire dans le
de bonnes conditions ensuite il faut que
nous assaénissions tout le
processus de
transformation de la viande c'est-à-dire
l'abattage nous en avons longuement
parlé et ensuite aussi que nous y voyons
clair la question qui m'a été posée qui
n'est pas du tout sortie nous avions
pourtant passé 10 minutes avec Monsieur
MOX dans l'émission que vous avez
rappelé l'autre soir à part à propos de
l'affaire spangero dont mon suppléant
bararteléi Aguerre était le PDG il n en
a pas eu un mot pourtant j'avais bien
expliqué la chose parce que je
connaissais très bien le dossier il faut
que la viande comme l'eau euh redevienne
au moins dans son contrôle une affaire
régalienne qui doit revenir main de
l'État et lorsque nous aurons mis de
l'ordre ici en France nous devons
commencer à mettre aussi en Europe et
faire en sorte que nos voisins européens
nous
suivent là ça va plutôt être chacun pour
soit Dieu pour tous mais bon c'est pour
ça que je vous dis que je me fais pas
beaucoup d'illusion votre av est à
quelle heure comment votre avion est à
quelle heure ah non mais on a du temps
on a du temps
ou votre philosophe
préféré
je pense
que Montaigne et l'esprit des loi euh a
permis
de de construire un peu ce que nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans la dans la
France
d'aujourd'hui sinon je crois que c'est
Socrate je pense que c'est Platon je
crois que c'est
oui c'est c'est plutôt dans la
démocratie euh très qui n'a pas duré
très longtemps d'ailleurs athénienne que
je les trouve je n'ai pas aujourd'hui si
aujourd'hui je suis je trouve euh un peu
euh comment je devrais dire résigné euh
mais je trouve que ce que dit euh
maintenant son nom méchappe là le Breton
qui est comme moi d'origine paysane euh
de
comment le Drillon non pas le Drillon
non euh celui qui apparu soudainement
sur match alors qu'il était il a créé sa
propre chaîne de télévision son nom
mchappe maintenant euh bref ça va me
revenir ah je que son Michel Michel
enfry Michel enfry aujourd'hui dit des
choses qui me semblent très justes sur
la
détérioration de notre
civilisation je le trouve un peu
pessimiste moi je pense qu'il a toujours
des raisons d'espérer par contre
l'analyse elle est elle est elle
est sur le terrorisme on fait quoi ben
sur le terrorisme d'abord on instruit et
j'ai un très grand projet d'instruction
publique pour la France combien ça va
coûter ah peu importe il y a pas de prix
c'est la seule manière de recréer un
lien dans notre pays et dans mon école
on parle français qu'on soit français
depuis 10000 ans ou qu'on soit français
depuis cette nuit par effraction on
rentre dans mon école et on ne sort pas
de l'école primaire sans avoir appris à
lire conter et écrire à se servir
d'Internet parce qu'on subit internet on
se sert pas d'internet je le dis
d'autant mieux que moi je ne le maîtrise
pas très bien euh
ensuite on apprend de langues euh au
choix parce que le CER terrorisme après
ça on on instruit la base pour endurcir
l'esprit critique des jeunes pour éviter
qu'il basculle dans X ou Y oui croyance
donc on fait quoi d'autre après ensuite
je suis les enfants de façon à ce que
autour de de l'instituteur parce que
dans le primiv c'est un instituteur
euh je lui donne la possibilité de se
faire assister par un parents d'élèves
parce que les parents d'élèves se
repassionnent de nouveau pour leurs
enfants peut y avoir des ménages romposé
des familles recomposé mais le parent
d'élèves ou la maman d'élèv est très
très présente donc c'est important celui
qui est déjà radicalisé euh à 2 ou 3 ans
il y en a pas beaucoup encore fort
heureusement c'est là qu'il faut
commencer à 14 16 ans qu'est-ce qu'on
fait à 14 16 ans c'est déjà beaucoup
plus difficile c'est pour ça que dans
mon système on narrive pas à 14 ou 16
ans radicaliser parce qu'on est suivi
fait pour la masse qui est déjà
radicalisée et bien euh nous avons créé
avec un un amiral euh cap jeess qui
comment s'appelle cet amiral c'est
l'amiral je sais rien je connais que lui
maintenant son nom m'échappe mais je je
je vous le dirai euh cap jeunesse qui
récupère ou qui approche avec des vrais
dealur des vrais patrons euh qui
reconverti ou qui qui qui essaent de
faire un très gros effort euh les
patrons des des cités et euh nous
engageons un travail de euh comment je
dirais de ressocialisation si l'on peut
dire c'est très difficile parce que ils
se sont construits totalement dans le
désir de détruire notre civilisation il
n'y a que ça pour eux dans la tête il y
a 15 ou 16 ans 17 ans 18 ans après c'est
complètement enquisté donc moi je fais
en sorte ça ne se produise plus pour ce
qui existe et bien je fais ce que j'ai
déjà fait depuis très longtemps dans ma
commune j'ai ouvert une maison pour des
jeunes où on prend euh des jeunes gens
qui ont fait de la prison et à qui on
propose du travail intelligent
intéressant par exemple on reconstruit
des cabanes en montagne on reconstruit
des granges on fait des petits chantiers
d'aduction d'eau potable qu'est-ce qu'on
fait avec les réfugiés avec les réfugiés
on fait en sorte qu'il en arrive à pas
un million de plus c'est pour ça que je
me suis rendu
euh en Syrie parce que vu la manière
intelligente avec laquelle on a géré le
premier million je me demande qu'est-ce
qui va se produire si on en a un million
de plus or ça peut très bien arrivé ça
c'est les réfugiés de guerre là je vous
parle des réfugiés économiques des
réfugiés économiques c'est c'est tout
mon projet avec l'Afrique c'est-à-dire
que il faut sans l'évangéliser sans
l'esclavagis
sans les déplacer c'est donner la
possibilité à des hommes qui sont qui
ont sont nés sur un territoire à pouvoir
y vivre dignement et décemment selon
leur juge et coutume c'est très
difficile parce que ça n'a jamais été
fait même la France n'a pas su le faire
pour ses enfants chez nous euh la
troisème a beaucoup fait mais n'a pas
respecté cela on a dû voilà on a fait
perdre les langues régionales on a
qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec les migrants
qui sont déjà là qui sont déjà en
approch
on ouvre plus les frontières on les
naturalise on fait comment est-ce que
est-ce que on fait une détection précoce
s'il y a des terroristes qui ont été
injectés dans ces flux de migrants
qu'est-ce que vous proposez par rapport
à tout ça est-ce que vous avez la
capacité de les loger est-ce que vous
avez la capacité d'appliquer les normes
internationales pour les camps de
réfugiés comment ça va se passer non il
y a rien de tout ça
ou très peu mais je pense que la
première des choses c'est quand même de
se protéger
parce que comment se protège comment on
se
protège je crois qu'il faut mettre en
place
une comme Donald Trump on fait des murs
non non je n'ai jamais voulu faire de
mur dans ma vie mais je crois qu'il faut
spécialiser ça commence à l'être mais il
faut intensifier les
moyens une équipe de psycholog c'est
pour ça qu'il faut que je rrouve des
marges financières sur des éléments
aussi vitauxx essentiels que ce combien
je dis pas je vais avoir tous ces
chiffres je vais savoir combien il y en
a il y en a bien plus de de 1000 ou 5000
moi en tout cas ce que j'ai vu quand je
fais mes virées nocturnes dans les cités
j'en ai vu beaucoup qui avaient envie de
mettre la France à terre et qui me l'ont
dit si on avait lu mon livre à l'époque
et si on avait voulu en faire un petit
quelque chose du rapport que j'avais
remis on s'en serait rendu compte il ne
s'en cache pas donc j'essaie de faire en
sorte non pas de leur envoyer forcément
les gendarmes parce que façon les
gendarmes n'y restent pas mais plutôt
des équipes préparées pour essayer de
parler comme le fait cap jeunesse et
essayer de les attirer sur un vrai
projet de société parce que et en même
temps essayer d'enlever un peu la haine
qu'il y a dans leur cœur parce qu'ils
ont dans leur cœur le souvenir de leur
grand-père qu'on a exploité et et qu'on
a parfois fait venir de pays lointain
pour venir fournir de la main d'œuvre
bon marché à nos prise le cannabis on
saute du coocalan jean Lassal est-ce
qu'il est pour ou contre le cannabis
dans quelle forme délivré par qui taxé
comment ou pas du tout Jean Lassal est
emmerdé sur ce sujet ah bon pourquoi
Jean lassal-ce qu'il a déjà fumé du
cannabis oui c'était
bien je peux pas dire que ça m'est
transporté je c'était à quelle occasion
alors j'en ai fumé la première fois à
l'occasion de no merveilleux voyage avec
les jeunes de lourdiosicher euh
au au Québec cétait sur un lac
magnifique il y avait de jolies filles
il y avait quelques garçons nous avions
été avec une embarcation et puis on a
fit surculer j'ai vu des étranges
petites cl Clopinette qui circulait j'ai
compris ce que c'était je me suis dit
tant qu'à faire jeis quand même voir
j'avais j'étais mère déjà donc j'avais
21 22 ans voilà et puis jeis FA large
pourvoir bon je me suis pas senti
radicalement transformé et j'en ai
refumé récemment à une
fête une très très grande fête qui est
organisée dans un lieu que je je connais
bien que je c hor de France parce que
sinon fr je peux même pas vous c'est
interdit de consommer des stupéfiants en
France vous savez monsieur le député
comment c'est interdit de consommer des
stupéfiants mais non mais je consommé
une bière et et le le le le pétard est
arrivé c'était 3h du matin on t'offre
une cigarette tu la refuses pas tu c'est
qu'au bout d'un moment que tu sens
qu'elle a une étrange odeur et c'est ta
femme qui te le confirme quand tu te
couches tu te dis oh qu'est-ce que tu
sens mauvais mais qu'est-ce que tu as
mais qu'est-ce que tu as fait et cetera
il m'est arrivé je pense de fumer un peu
aussi
à nuit
debout mais pas entière B qu'est-ce
qu'on fait alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait je
pense qu'il y a unre travail très
important à faire tout c'est de nouveau
pareil ça redémarre de l'école de
l'école que je veux de nouveau très
structuré organisé avec un maître
d'école qui soit sanctuirisé par mon
élection mais sanctuirisé une
sanctuirisation républicaine de façon à
ce que personne ne puisse sortir de mon
école sans avoir appris toutes ces
disciplines ensuite je continue à suivre
ceux qui ont la capacité de faire des
études de langue bien je les oriente de
l'éducation nationale en 2016 c'est
c'est combien oh je n'en ai aucune idée
je sais que c'est le 2e je coi 2e budget
euh mais je ne sais pas le chiffre exact
je veux le savoir je veux par tout ça
pour l'instant je suis un député je suis
isolé hein donc je n'ai pas toutes les
capacités d'un parti lorsque je serai
Président je je vais avoir tous ces
moyens c'est important que je vous
précise ça parce que ce qui est
important en politique c'est vision
c'est l'intuition c'est de comprendre ce
qui arrive à notre temps qu'est-ce qu'on
fait avec le cannabis avec cannabis je
vous dis pour l'instant je n'ai pas de
réponse parce que je connais des jeunes
qui ont une addiction au cannabis je
sais pourquoi ils l'ont tu parce que ils
sont se sont trouvés dans des groupes et
n'importe qui d'entre nous se serait
trouvé dans ces groupes aurait fumé du
cannabis euh et quand il y a une
addiction c'est très difficile de de de
de de passer du jour au lendemain à zéro
donc il faut se donner les moyens sur du
long terme de faire en sorte qu'on nit
plus besoin ou alors ou alors ou alors
il faudra le si vraiment c'est
impossible il faudra comme l'ont fait
beaucoup d'autres pays
le le tolérer euh mais très franchement
je suis emmerdé par cette question c'est
une rare qui m'emmerde parce que j'ai
pas une vision saine je sens qu'il ne
faut pas le faire parce que une
addiction de plus dans un monde aussi
dangereux et difficile c'est peut-être
le pas de trop est-ce que vous avez déjà
vu un alcoolique se battre
oui est-ce que vous avez déjà vu un
fumeur de joint se
battre
non non je crois pas il il m'a pas
semblé je l' j'ai plutôt une parenthèse
euh passons à un dernier sujet j'ai
répondu aussi du TAC cont tac non mais
tant mieux il y a pas de souci c'est
c'est le principe de notre chaîne
Youtube c'est sans coupure ni montage du
tacot tac on prépare rien on est financé
par personne mais c'est du vrai au MOS
c'est du vrai c'est d'homme à homme bon
un conseil pour les jeunes générations
croire un eux c'est-à-dire reprendre en
vie je crois qu'on a une force de vie en
nous on la ressent à un peu à tous les
âges de la vie le tout de savoir si on
s'écoute ou si on écoute tout tout son
entourage qui vous qui vous pousse à
faire autre chose moi j'ai très bien
connu ça tout au long de de ma vie euh
je dis aux jeunes euh faites ce que vous
ressentez bien euh faites en sorte de
rester le plus possible maître de votre
destin c'est très difficile quand on est
dans une dans une bon lieue tel que nous
les connaissons aujourd'hui c'est très
difficile quand on est au fond d'une
campagne où il y a rien et où on s'prête
à redevenir des B de grands chemins mais
il y a toujours une une espèce de de
chance de bonne étoile pour celui qui ne
renonce pas à se prendre en charge et à
vivre sa vie il y a même une très grande
fierté à retirer et je leur dis
engagez-vous dans la politique euh
engagez-vous vous dans le combat des
idées lisez instruisez-vous allez à la
source vérifiez et il n'y a pas d'âge
pour ça et amusez-vous aussi parce que
la jeunesse s'est pas fait non plus pour
être vécu comme un drame
reappropriez-vous votre jeunesse merci
Jean je regarde mes collègues si vous
avez des questions non c'est bon non
non non bon ben Jean Lassal merci bien
merci à vous et je doit dire je veux pas
sirer les pompes parce que vous savez
que je peux ne pas les sirer si j'ai pas
envie j'aime beaucoup ce type
d'entretien parce que ça me permet de
mesurer l'immense progrès de préparation
qui me reste à faire en seulement un
mois pour que je sois vraiment
opérationnel lorsque les hommes de votre
talent m'interrogeront mais peut-être
pas avec les idées objectives qui sont
les vôtres vous savez ce que je ne sais
pas sa pas mais vous n'essayz pas de on
essaie pas d'être objectif on essaie
simplement d'être les mercenaires de
notre communauté on a reçu énormément de
questions à vous poser concernant
l'Europe concernant vos positions par
rapport à l'Europe par rapport à
l'élevage l'écologie par rapport à
l'écologie dans votre propre région et
et des gens qui vous tire dessus à
gauche et à droite nous on essaie
simplement d'être synthétique parce que
on sent que la tempête arrive et que les
choses ne sont pas poser calmement pour
pouvoir appréhender correctement les
problèmes c'est pour ça qu'on ne triche
pas on fait sans montage ni coupure
qu'on n pas de fiche vous pouvez en
témoigner de notre propre
organisation on l'a fait pour rétablir
des du dialogue entre les
hommes écoutez je souhaiterais
simplement que vous soyez un peu plus
nombreux Jean l sal merci merci à vous
[Musique]
merci